[Music]
guys welcome to another beautiful
morning and we're getting ready to go
fishing
we're going to a different spot a little
further away today and we're bringing
the overnight gear so it's a really
we're getting serious
getting the bivi and bedchairs sleeping
bags fishing gear got to get it all in
there this is the first time since I
landed in Spain and we've seen any
clouds but it's supposed to be really
nice today supposed to be in the 60s
well guys we're headed to this fishing
spot which I don't know anything about
other than its upstream and about two
hours away
we're excited it's gonna be our first
overnight trip
well we stopped in this little village
here and there's a tackle shop that's
open we're gonna grab licenses for this
County and check out some gear - that's
a serious door bill look Nate it's a
catfish big swimbaits their boats for
baiting up oh these just clunkers so
many things here I want to buy and so
very few things I can fit in my luggage
we're driving through fields of rosemary
right now it just smells amazing I don't
know what it is about this spot that
just screams big fish to me we're here
about 10 minutes and the police just
showed up and we had her license checked
which luckily everything was in order
but yeah you don't see that too often I
think I've been checked maybe once or
twice in the last two years so you wanna
come help you want to help
heart you're doing a great job Nate oh
yeah that's seven and for you I'll take
that all day long
new personal best 37 that is awesome I
was a huge fish man you hurt my back
lifting that thing but AMA go casas back
out and we're gonna go get another one
I've barely got our rods out we had one
hit they didn't hook up and then we've
just landed that fish and we haven't
been here long at all so I think it's a
good sign I just this place just has all
sorts of good vibes about it luckily
I've got myself a good chair Nathan's
got plenty of mud and sand to play with
so I think we can we can dig in for the
long haul here these are pig pen prints
wild pigs that's a cat kitty cat
William Oh high-pitched um down here the
white [__] ain't nice my favorite thing
about Spain so far is the ham sandwiches
this is all I've been eating for like
all week it's been brilliant you know
I'm actually filming two different
videos for my two different YouTube
channels right now one channel the
outdoor boys YouTube channel i'll post
the the trip the whole behind-the-scenes
the traveling the v-log part and for my
other channel the catfish and carp
youtube channel i'll be posting just the
fishing stuff you know with a lot more
detailed explanations of what gear were
using and what we're doing and things
like that so if you want to see all the
behind the scenes stuff and cute
Nathan's stuff watch the outdoor boys
video if you want to see all the fishing
in and out and all the details about the
fishing
check out the catfish and carp video
I'll put links in the description to
both alright next setting up the the
bivi which is the the carp fishing tent
me they actually sell sleeping bags and
cots and tents specifically designed for
carp fishing well the Sun is beginning
to set on a very successful day but
we're not giving up we're gonna be
fishing all night long and it's gonna be
it's gonna be exciting and got a little
fire pit we dug here and some driftwood
so we're gonna have a nice little cozy
fire and Nick's over there cooking up a
curry which I have to confess I'm very
excited about oh that smells fantastic
already
well thank you okay good yeah all right
all right buddy won't you lay down and
go to sleep okay well it's the end of a
great day and we're still fishing I've
got my alarms on and the rods in the
water and something comes along and
invites it's gonna wake me up hopefully
and we're out there and get it so but
everything for tonight
it's good night and I'll see you guys in
the morning well good morning Sun just
barely came up and I think there's a
little Roach or something on the end of
this end its life there we go
hey bud you have a good night's rest you
warm you ready for some snake sausage we
were sitting here in our tents last
night you can hear wild pigs going crazy
out there sounded like a couple piglets
got eaten or something it was just crazy
and there was foxes running up and down
and cranes and storks a lot of animals
here and you look at the prints in the
mud see this this place is alive there's
lots of lots of wildlife here well guys
this is a pretty nice way to watch your
fishing rods we're just sitting here you
can see right off the front door
there's our rod pod just hanging out and
the fish bites we're gonna be ready you
did it Nate you just landed it good job
well Nathan that is a chunky fish oh
well I'm thinking mid-30s Tommy's best
is thirty six and a half maybe maybe you
can beat Tommy's best here oh man look
at the hump on his back a bit bigger
than Quasimodo
be 535 clothes is I'm gonna good job
buddy high five back all right 35 pound
beast of a common on Knicks special
brand boilies so that was awesome good
job Nate way to get your hand on a
Spanish Ebro carp well the Sun is
properly set and things have quieted
down so we're gonna go back to the house
and sleep in a bed tonight and just take
it easy and we're gonna try to come back
as early as we can tomorrow morning and
and see what happens but this has just
been an absolute riot and had a good
time but Nathan here is super excited to
go back and play with his little friend
you excited go see your best friend all
right we made it out of the woods and
back here to Reba Roy the Ebro and get
some dinner and Nathan's gonna get to
see his best buddy
[Music]
[Applause]
our last day in Spain is a foggy one
that look good good we got to get you
that's you all fed up it's our last day
of fishing so we've got to we've got to
catch some big fish today huh oh yeah
there was ice on the car last night was
bitterly cold I'm glad we didn't stay in
the tents it was there's ice on the car
but the sun's coming out today
looks like we're gonna have a beautiful
final day well it is a beautiful night
the moon is falling we are having a
great time but it's late and I need to
get this boy to bed because we have a
long flight tomorrow morning so I think
we're gonna call but we have had an
amazing time I've got a brand new
species of fish I've never never seen
before and we caught five amazing carp
four of which were over 30 pounds well
we better get him and to get him home
and yeah we'll see you guys in the
morning
guys it's early morning and it's time to
head back to Virginia we've got to drive
about two hours to Barcelona
there is a thick layer of ice on
everything I hope mixed and warm out
there on the bank
he still out there fishing well there's
one last thing we need to do before we
go home we need to find a nice souvenir
for Mom
this is gonna be a little tricky we've
been out in the sticks so it hasn't
exactly been a lot of shopping
opportunities but we're hoping that
around the airport we'll find something
nice so last-minute souvenir shopping
here we go we made it to Barcelona got
the car returned it just took us an hour
to get through passport control people
started missing their flights and bunch
of people started lying jumping and crap
and the other people start yelling at
other people about line jumping I was
like holy crap someone's going to get
arrested it was interesting what we're
through and this is why you come to the
airport like four hours early when
you're traveling internationally in
Europe all right buddy you ready to get
on the plane
well guys we landed in Heathrow and I
got my wife at least one souvenir so not
coming home empty-handed but we got a
couple hours to kill so we'll walk
around a little bit and maybe grab some
fish and chips if you liked this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys YouTube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for watching